every week my daughter's school sends
home their sheets and blankets from nap
time to wash I send it to school with
one of my thongs lodged into the corner
and was really confused when my thong
came home in her school bag it took me a
few hours to connect the dots but I
wanted to crumble into a ball I mean
listen real teachers know you know what
I think it's better that it was a thong
and it's like cute and it's like oh this
girl's like cute sexy mom versus like a
big pair of bloomers like obviously I'm
putting myself in her shoes like if a
pair of my underwear made it out into
the wild without my guidance
um like I would literally have to like
enter the witness protection program
because my personal style of underwear
is like the bigger the better you know
the more it looks like a hospital also
it's like underwear that was like once
white and is now top mustard yum mustard
like yeah I would just hope it was one
of the good ones